bueno tras 20 años de guerra y de
presencia de las tropas estadounidenses
y también de la otan en el talibán no
sólo no se ha reducido ni fue controlado
por el contrario parecen más
fortalecidos no hoy en dos semanas
avanzaron sobre casi todo el territorio
del país como interpreta usted esto
lo primero eso demuestra el fracaso de
un modelo de democratización por manu
militari decir la democracia es una cosa
que se crea como un proceso no que se
impone a través de la fuerza segundo que
la decisión de eeuu de invadir y
permanecer allí bajo una lógica de
campaña cívico-militares pero no de
acompañamiento a un desarrollo real y
serio pues pasa factura y tercero que no
haber atendido a las causas del
conflicto a las causas reales de la
crisis lleva fácilmente a que un grupo
de ciudadanos termine por abrazar
proyectos para artistas víctor y que
representa para las mujeres y las niñas
el regreso del grupo talibán
pero cuando yo estuve en kabul y
jalalabad a una de las cosas más
conmovedoras era el regreso y la
celebración que tenían las mujeres de
poder volver a las escuelas a los
trabajos a la vida social si bien es
cierto aquello pues dista mucho de una
cosa ideal era mucho mejor que lo que se
vivía hasta el año 2001 de hecho creo
que lo único que tiene para mostrar eeuu
en materia de la ocupación lo único
positivo fue el regreso de las niñas a
la escuela se habla de 3.5 millones de
niñas que volvieron a la escuela pero lo
que se observaba por ejemplo hace 23
días general es que ya les prohíben ir
al trabajo ir a las universidades por lo
cual va a haber una afectación directa a
los derechos humanos de todas las
personas pero particularmente de las
mujeres y de las niñas en lo que tiene
que ver con la educación ahora otro de
los grupos más vulnerables son los
refugiados y aquí juega un rol clave en
los países de la comunidad internacional
verdad
sin duda el número de refugiados se mide
en millones desde la ocupación de la
unión soviética luego la guerra de los
señores de la guerra luego la llegada de
los talibán al poder y la ocupación de
eeuu entonces en millones sobre todos
los países más afectados han sido iran
que queda el occidente y pakistán que
quede al sur de afganistán brevemente
víctor última pregunta considera que
podría producirse una suerte de efecto
expansivo efecto dominó y que otros
grupos islamistas ganen más poder en sus
respectivos territorios
pues estamos cansados de decir de muchas
maneras que la crisis de los grupos
islamistas radicales se resuelve
atendiendo las causas y no las
consecuencias así nació el grupo talibán
y así nació al qaeda así nació el estado
islámico esperemos que esto no sea la
cuna de un nuevo grupo que afectaría no
solamente la sociedad ghana y
particularmente las mujeres sino a toda
la comunidad internacional